quelques jours il ya un papier qui est
sorti sur arcade parlem que oliver et
soundarajan qui a énormément agité la
communauté mathématique notamment ceux
qui travaillaient sur la théorie des
nombres premiers
est ce que suggère ce papier en gros ne
le prouve pas ce qui suggère c'est que
les nombres premiers consécutifs ont
tendance à ne pas avoir le même derniers
chiffres et ça ça a surpris énormément
de gens dans la communauté mathématique
il ya pas mal de théoriciens des nombres
qui ont dit qu'ils ont fini sur le cul
quand ils ont découvert cela et
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de vous
expliquer pourquoi ils ont trouvé ça
surprenant alors et un nombre premier
j'imagine que vous savez ce que c'est
mais je vais quand même leur expliquer
le nombre premier c'est un nombre qui ne
peut pas être décomposé comme le produit
de nombreux strictement plus petits par
exemple le nombre 8 peut se décomposer
en deux fois 4 dont 2 nombreux plus
petit alors que le nombre 11 ne peut pas
être décomposé comme le produit de deux
nombres plus petit et donc les nombres
premiers jouent un rôle central dans
l'histoire des mathématiques et dans
l'intérêt des mathématiciens tam en
théorie des nombres pour pas mal de
raisons mais notamment pour des raisons
historiques cesson et nombre qui sont
assez facile à définir que beaucoup de
gens ont étudié et sur lesquels beaucoup
de questions ont été posées mais peu de
réponses ont été apportées à des
questions d'apparence très simple goy
avec les nombres premiers c'est très
facile de créer un nouveau problème qui
laissera scotché qui collera
complètement toute la communauté
mathématique pendant des décennies voire
des siècles voire des millénaires par
exemple un des problèmes classiques et
des nombres premiers
c'est les licences de nombreux premiers
jumeaux qui auront déjà l'antiquité le
premier nombres premiers jumeaux plutôt
la conjecture des nombres premiers
jumeaux sadique il existe un nombre
infini de nombres premiers
tel que le nombre 1er juillet juste
après vient seulement deux nombres après
par exemple les nombreuses 5 et 7 de
sont séparés que de deux et ce sont tous
les deux des nombres premiers
donc ils forment une paire de nombreux
premiers jumeaux de même façon 17 et 19
sont des premiers jumeaux ainsi que 30
ainsi que 39 et 41 ans sans doute est
donc ce problème il a été inventé son
hôte par pythagore va pouvoir bien avant
donc y'a rien au moins deux mille ans
ainsi ce n'est beaucoup plus et des
générations de mathématiciens ont
cherché à apporter une réponse à ce
problème mais ce problème est encore un
problème ouvert et en fait c'était une
très très grande surprise quand un pas
énorme vers la résolution de ce problème
a été fait en 2013 par le mathématicien
chinois qui vit aux états unis
li tanjong fait ce que little joy a
prouvé s'il existe un nombre infime de
père de nombreux promis qu'ils soient
séparés de moins de plusieurs millions
donc ça peut pas être débile voire
complètement parolier hautmont premiers
jumeaux mais juste avant soeur n'avait
aucune idée du nombre nombres premiers
séparés par moins d'une quantité finie
et donc ça c'est la première fois de
l'histoire qu'il y avait un résultat
dans ce genre il a été largement
amélioré ensuite par toute une équipe de
mathématiciens qui ont collaboré
ensemble sur internet qui ont réussi à
réduire ce nombre
quelques millions à 246 aujourd'hui on
sait qu'il existe un nombre infini de
nombres premiers
séparés par mois que 246 et là il faut
continuer à réussir à descendre ce
nombre également faudra ramener ce
nombre à deux puisque si on arrive à
promet approuvé ce théorème pour un
nombre d'écarts égale à 2 en fait on
prouve la toile des nombres premiers
jumeaux cependant a priori les experts
pensent que ça ne sera pas possible d'y
arriver de réduire à deux en utilisant
les méthodes qui ont été utilisés par
elton john et donc les mathématiciens
pur n'ont aucune preuve aujourd'hui du
de la conjecture des nombres premiers
jumeaux pourtant tout cela me semble
quasiment tous croient en la conjecture
et ça ça peut pas ultra surprenant on a
en a à faire des mathématiciens prix est
des êtres rationnels 6 ans et plus
rationnel et un sens ou du moins des
êtres dotés d'une rigueur absolue où la
meilleure rigueur qui existe dans
l'espèce humaine
et pourtant ils sont persuadés qu'une
conjecture qui nous paraissaient
approuvé est vrai et ça quand on y
réfléchit
je sais déjà super intrigant comment
peut-on avoir une telle croyance en
quelque chose pour laquelle on n'a
aucune preuve quand on est mathématicien
et bien la réponse à cette question
vient de ce qu'on appelle les modèles
aléatoire des nombres
premier et ça ça peut paraître super
bizarre parce qu'après un nombre premier
n'est pas aléatoire il n'y a aucune
raison d'être aléatoire en fait les
nombres ils sont déterministe et le fait
qu'ils soient premiers noms ne dépend
pas d'un tirage au sort a priori dieu ne
joue pas aux dés et façon même si jouer
aux dés il ne choisit pas la prime alité
dénombre il ne peut pas la choisir c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamentalement
intrasèquement déterminé par la nature
même des nombres mais alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on utilise ses modèles
aléatoire des nombres premiers
dingo ce premier à confiture et qui s
était un bon modèle des nombres premiers
que de considérer qu'un endroit tiré
aléatoirement en nombre entre à thouars
mans a une probabilité d'être premier
qui est inversement proportionnelle au
nombre de ces chiffres donc si je prends
un nombre comme 5237 la probabilité que
ce nombre soit premier d'après un modèle
basique des nombres premiers serait un
sur son nombre de chiffres ou plutôt
proportionnelle à 1 sur son nombre de
chiffres qui seraient donc propre or
c'est là un sur quatre en fait gosses à
conjecturer une valeur beaucoup plus
précise de cette probabilité puisqu'il a
conjecturé qu'elle était égal à 1 sur le
logarithme dîner paie rien de ce nombre
n donc je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails sur ce que veut dire de le
garric n'était rien en gros pour la
première fois de l'histoire gosses
proposer un modèle aléatoire des nombres
en fait c'est pas exactement c'est ce
qu'il a fait ce qui a plutôt dit c'est
que le nombre de nombres premiers plus
petit que n va est à peu près une fois
cette probabilité
c'est à dire l / le logarithme n'est pas
rien de haine donc la conjecture de
gosses plus formellement dit que le
nombre nombre premier petit renne veux
être à synthétiques ont également fait à
peu près égal si vous voulez pas vous
déranger avec les termes techniques à
haisnes / le logan n'était rien de haine
est en fait les mêmes trouver une
meilleure estimation de ca qui
correspond encore mieux aux modèles
aléatoire que je viens de décrire qui
utilisent le logarithme dit intégral je
parlerai dans les détails et ensuite
riman qui est l étudiant de gauche a
donné une généralisation de cette
lecture de go ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'hypothèse de riemann qui
en plus de dire que le nombre d'ong
premier plus petit qu on n est à peu
près égale logarithme intégrale de
quand il fit aussi les ors qui est fait
à l'aide de la fonction et avec un petit
peu compliqué je crois savoir qu'elle
j'y fais une vidéo à ce sujet donc je
mettrais un lien vers la vidéo de ji
quelque part bref la préfecture de gosse
finira par être prouvée par adam arrêt
de laval et poussins vers les années
1900 et c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le théorème des nombres
premiers
donc ce qui est marrant dans cette
histoire c'est que le modèle aléatoire
de gosse a fini par être prouvée en un
certain sens par un théorème
mathématique
bref tout ça pour dire qu'aujourd'hui
les mathématiciens ont une grande
confiance en ses modèles aléatoire des
nombres premiers ce qui pourrait devoir
ce qui peut pas vraiment bizarre est
marrant mais toujours est il que c'est
vrai et ça c'est parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à trouver de régularité dans les
nombres premiers et c'est vraiment si ce
que suggère l'hypothèse de riemann il ya
d'autres exemples historiques ou ce
modèle aléatoire des nombres à formuler
une conjecture qui a ensuite été prouvé
mathématiquement il s'agit du théorème
une plutôt d'une perte généralisée du
théorème de dire ikhlef ce toit mais il
commence à vraiment nous intéresser à
puisqu'il parle des derniers chiffres
des nombres premiers et donc à part 2
qu' un nombre premier
aucun des ombres premier ne finit par
024 six ou huit de même façon aucun
nombre premier finit par 1,5 à part 5
donc si j'enlève de l5 tous les nombres
premiers
fini ce soit par un soin par 1,3 soit
par 1,7 soit par un neuf
maintenant dans le cadre des modèles
aléatoire des nombres premiers
il n'y a pas plus de raisons pour qu'un
nombre finirez par un que par 3 par que
par un set que par 9 6 surtout si on
tire la probabilité qu'un nombre de
vienne premier de façon aléatoire et
donc n'a mené en utilisant les modèles
est aléatoire des nombres premiers à
conjecturer le fait qu'il ya autant de
nombres premiers qui finissent par un 1
que parrain iii que par un set que par
un neuf et alors ça qu'on fait des
simulations numériques on se rend compte
que c'est pas tout à fait le cas
en fait comprend des petits nombres
c'est pas tout à fait vrai en fait il ya
un biais qu'on appelle le biais de
twitter
mais ce biais disparaît comprend des
nombres de plus en plus grands et en
fait la généralisation du théorème de
dire il est dit que tous les derniers
chiffres 1 300 et neuf sont écu probable
qu'au regard des nombreux très très très
très très grand alors là je parle pour
la base 10
bien sûr tout ce que je dis est vrai
pour n'importe quelle base et le
théorème généralisée désiré créé par de
toutes les bases au général bon
maintenant essayons d'appliquer sa à la
conjecture des nombres premiers jumeaux
avec un modèle très très simpliste des
nombres premiers donc je vais dire qu'un
nombre est premier avec probabilité 1
sur le guen de trucs de base qui est
complètement faux puisqu'il ignore des
régularités comme le fait que tous les
nombres pairs soldes ne sont pas promis
mais bref supposer que ce soit vrai
alors la probabilité que de nombreux
prix ensemble qu'ils ont une paire de
l'ong par exemple séparer de 2 soit tous
les deux premiers en même temps peut
être à peu près 1 sur le guen au carré
donc maintenant si je regarde nombre de
paires de nombres premiers jumeaux plus
petit que n ça va être à peu près égale
à la somme des probabilités que les
pères dénombre séparer de deux fois tous
les deux premiers c'est à dire la somme
d 1 sur logan au carré et ça ça tend
vers l'infini et donc ce petit argument
suggère qu'il existe un nombre infini de
nombreux premiers jumeaux et en fait ça
ou plutôt des modèles un petit peu ce au
plus sophistiqué que celui là la raison
principale pour laquelle les
mathématiciens purpan ce qui existe un
nombre infini de nombres premiers
jumeaux et donc si on en arrive à
remettre en cause ce modèle aléatoire
des nombres premiers dont on va devoir
remettre en cause aussi notre intuition
et que du coup va peut-être falloir
changer la façon dont on fait de la
recherche sur les nombres premiers
notamment jumeaux et ben justement le
papier qui est sorti il ya quelques
jours
remède justement en cause ce modèle
aléatoire des nombres premiers puisque à
priori si on prend un modèle aléatoire
basique des nombres premiers
et ben si on a un nombre premier qui
finit par 1 1
il n'y a pas plus de raisons que le
suivant finissent pas un 3-1 7,9 tué par
un un commando a pris est passé de 1 à 3
est aussi probable que de passer leur à
un bien ce que montre ce papier c'est
que la réponse est non il y à un billet
un peu comme le biais de chimie tiers
pour en tout cas des noms qui sont pas
extrêmement grand sauf que ce biais est
beaucoup beaucoup plus grand que celui
de thierry tiers alors malheureusement
le papier n'arrive pas à voir une preuve
de cela ce que le papier fait c'est
entre autres donné des résultats
numériques pour aller dans ce sens donc
à un moment dans le papier il ya un
tableau qui donne les nombres de
transition entre les derniers chiffres
de nombreux premiers consécutif et là on
voit par exemple que passer de 1
1 est presque deux fois moins probable
que de passer de 1 à 7
alors mon premier réflexe quand j'ai vu
ce tableau je me suis demandé si c'est
pas simplement dû au fait que si on
tirait au hasard
après avoir tiré un ouvrier un nombre
qui commence par 1,3 du cac avant de
tirer celui qui finit par un set puis
après celui par 1,9 puis après seulement
c'est suis parent et du coup simplement
à cause de cet ordre dans lequel on tire
façon naturelle on s'attend à ce que le
1 soit plus suivi par 1,3 que par un set
que par un neuf et que par 1 1
du coup j'ai fait quelques petits
calculs et ango je me suis convaincu
tout seul que ce tableau était pas très
convaincant alors j'ai toutefois un
petit bémol parce que c'est quand même
vachement bizarre que la preuve était
que après 1,1
il y en 3 soit la même que 1 soit suivie
de sept ça c'est vachement bizarre donc
il rase des trucs bizarres dans ce
tableau morose comme moi ça m'a pas tant
convaincu que ça du fait qu'il y ait un
billet et qu' un nombre premier nathan
ça ne pas vouloir être suivie par un
nombre premier dont le dernier chiffre
est le même mais il y a un autre tableau
qui m'a l'argent plus convaincus qui
correspond à la base 3 parce que mon art
garder jusque-là dans en passe 10 mai
tous les raisonnements que j'ai fait je
peux le faire aussi en basse trois
heures en basse trois quarts - les
nombres premiers ne vont pas finir par
un zéro parce qu'ils seront divisible
par trois mois par trois du coup les
derniers chiffres des nombres premiers
en base 3 qui ne sont pas trop à
lui-même seront forcément un ou deux et
donc là le résultat numérique qui porte
sur les premiers 1 million de nombres
premiers
c'est que leurs derniers chiffres en
base 3 va avoir tendance à transitionner
dans mon premier à son suivant entre 1
et 2 plutôt que rester le même et le
phénomène n'a est beaucoup plus
important que c'est vraiment
impressionnant et en particulier avec
des modèles à aléatoire basique des
nombres premiers n'obtient pas du tout
ça là si on regarde la probabilité de
transition par rapport à la probabilité
du reste le même il est 30 fois 100 plus
grands
alors qu'avec un modèle aléatoire de
base moi j'ai obtenu 10% fin donc ça
c'est vraiment pas une preuve mais
un élément observe d'observation un
évident en ce qu'on appellera c'est en
anglais qui suggère qu'il faut renoncer
aux modèles aléatoire des nombres
premiers
et si on commence à renoncer aux modèles
aléatoire de mon premier et 20 ça remet
en cause notre intuition sur le fait ou
non que les nombres premiers jumeaux ce
ton nombre infini autrement dit ça
change complètement notre vision des
nombres premiers en général quand on a
toutes nos intuitions la manière dont on
va faire de la recherche par rapport à
eux
alors là j'ai parlé un peu vite parce
que se tient sur ce qu'on a utilisées
c'est un modèle aléatoire des nombres
premiers extrêmement primitif
il existe en fait des modèles des
nombres premiers qui sont plus
sophistiqués notamment il y en a un qui
se repose sur la première conjecture de
hardy littlewood qu'on appelle aussi la
conjecture quintuple qui est une
conjecture qui porte sur les
constellations de nombreux premiers
prenez une suite de nombres pairs par
exemple 4 8 22 la conjecture dardy
littlewood ce qu'a dit c'est que la
probabilité qu'un nombre m tirent au
hasard
soit elle que n n + 4 n + 8 et n + 22
soit tous premiers en même temps est
égale à une certaine formule que je vais
pas expliquer ici parce qu'elle est
super compliqué mais en gros ça fournit
un nouveau modèle aléatoire des nombres
premiers
tel que je viens de raconter c'est le
modèle qui est basée sur la conjoncture
de rares des ltte woods mais vrai
collector est rare d little ou d un truc
un peu plus compliqué mais prouvable
mathématiquement et donc ce que les
auteurs du papier il ya quelques jours
ont fait dans leur papier c'est qu'ils
ont réussi à expliquer les billets
observé à l'aide de ce modèle fondé sur
la conjecture de rares littlewood en
tout cas je montrais que les résultats
numériques étaient à peu près consistant
avec cette conjecture
et donc ça c'est les amener à faire
notre conjectures qui donc ce qu'ils ont
conjecturer sais que la probabilité
d'une transition plutôt que pas de
transition était en effet plus grande
mais qu'elle elle est diminuée un
certain rythme un rythme beaucoup plus
lent que le biais de sherritt chef mais
qui avait comme compte finir par
diminuer quand on prend des nombres très
très très grand ils ont même quantifier
la vitesse à laquelle c'est ce biais
diminue et ce qui est amusant en fait
dans cette histoire c'est qu'en fait ils
ont
il pas confirmé en fait par
l'observation le modèle aléatoire
hôpitaux la conjecture 2d littlewood
finalement une approche quasiment
scientifique quasiment à la physicienne
des mathématiques c'est à dire des
mathématiques où il ya une certaine
vérité qui est déterministe mais cette
réalité est beaucoup trop compliqué et
difficile d'en parler directement du
coup ce que l'on fait pour avoir des
intuitions sur la réalité mathématique
c'est construire des modèles aléatoire
dont on sait qu'ils sont faux mais qui
vont nous permettre de faire beaucoup
plus rapidement des espèces de prévision
de les intuitions de des prédictions
intuitive sur la real la réalité
mathématique qui est pourtant et
déterministe tout cas qu'on y
réfléchisse ça remet un petit peu en
perspective le but de physique par
exemple pour des sciences en général
peut-être qu'on ne cherche pas du tout
la vérité est que même on souhaite s'en
éloigner parce que les toits sont trop
compliquées est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est plus développé des modèles avec
lesquels on peut avoir un haut niveau
d'intuition peu et si le modèle ne colle
pas aux observations et ben on va
vouloir le rejeter ou en tout cas perdre
en confiance en le modèle alors que l
inverse si le modèle fait une prédiction
qui se trouve être confirmés soit en
mathématiques par un théorème soir par
des observations numérique et ben on va
gagner en confiance en cette ce modèle
où cette théorie en tout cas les
mathématiciens sont fades à de nouveaux
résultats notamment parce qu'elle remet
en cause leur intuition sur les nombres
et nombreux premiers en particulier du
coup je pense qu'il ya de très bonnes
chances que dans les mois les années à
venir lire encore de plein de nouveaux
résultats surprenants sur les nombres
premiers qui vont surgir du fait de
cette nouvelle ré interprétation
intuitive que les mathématiciens vont
avoir des nombres premiers
et ça c'est plutôt cool